This is a download from BBC Learning English.
To find out more, visit our website.
Hello, this is 6 Minute English from BBC Learning English. I'm Neil.
And I'm Sam.
When you were a teenager, did your parents worry that you were watching too much television, Sam?
They used to tell me that watching too much TV would turn my eye square.
But they were only joking.
I don't think it's all bad news, Neil.
In fact, in this programme, we'll be taking a look at a new report,
which finds little evidence to link technology with mental health problems in adolescence.
That's young people who are in the process of developing from children into adults.
I'm not convinced, Sam.
Think about how much time youngsters spend staring at screens every day.
True, but unlike passively watching television,
today's technology is interactive, connecting teenagers to their friends around the world.
Well, maybe my quiz question will change your mind.
Are you ready?
On average, how many hours per day do British teenagers spend on their screens?
Is it a, five and a half hours, b, six and a half hours, or c, seven and a half hours?
I'll say it's b, six and a half hours.
That sounds a lot to me.
Well, whatever Neil thinks, a new study from the Oxford Internet Institute,
paints a more hopeful picture.
The study analysed data from over 400,000 British and American teenagers
and found little or no link between adolescence tech use and mental health problems.
Listen to Gareth Mitchell and Gillen Boddington, co-presenters of BBC World Services Digital Planet,
as they discuss the report's findings.
Gillen Boddington, you've been looking at some of the findings yourself.
Haven't you?
So, what's your response so far?
Were you expecting, Gillen, to see some kind of smoking guns, some kind of link that would say,
here we are, here are the harms.
Not really, because I think we're at a point where teenagers are much more savvy than many adults think.
So, you know, we are at risk.
All of us as journalists and research community to assume, maybe,
this is much more terrible problem than we understand.
Because if I know the teenagers around me,
and one thing that they do all have is app lockers on their sites,
and they are actually quite aware of the addiction problems,
the design, you know, design for addiction.
Many people assume that social media harms teenagers,
so Gareth asked Gillen whether she was expecting to find a smoking gun in the report.
The expression a smoking gun means evidence that proves something is true.
For example, evidence proving that technology is harmful to young people.
But Gillen doesn't think this is true.
Actually, she calls teenagers savvy,
meaning that they have practical knowledge of technology
and a good understanding of how to use it.
One example of teenagers being technologically savvy is their use of app blockers,
software that prevents unwanted apps and websites from popping up
and allows users to set timers, which limit screen time.
And reducing screen time is important because nowadays,
most video games in social media are designed for addiction,
intended to manipulate human psychology to make the user once a keep playing.
But it seems that today's adolescents are savvy enough to know how to use
electronic devices sensibly.
How else can we explain the fact that, according to this research,
there's no clear link between using tech and mental health problems?
Yes, that's certainly the view of the research team leader,
Dr. Mati Vore.
Here he is speaking with BBC World Service Programme Digital Planet
about an interesting and very modern term.
See if you can hear it.
We often hear the term digital native.
You know, you grow up with a device in your hand almost.
And then it's not a surprise that you are skilled in using those technologies to your benefit.
Did you hear the expression, Dr. Vore used Sam?
Yes, he called teenagers digital natives,
meaning someone who is very familiar and comfortable using computers and digital technology
because they've grown up with them.
So maybe there are benefits to spending hours looking at screens after all.
In my quiz question, I asked Sam about the average daily screen time for British teenagers.
I said it was B six and a half hours.
Which was the correct answer, very savvy of you, Sam.
Okay, let's recap the vocabulary from this program about the impact of tech on adolescence.
That's young people who are developing into adults.
Today's adolescence are digital natives, people who are very familiar with digital technology
because they've grown up with it.
If you are savvy, you have a good practical understanding of something.
A smoking gun refers to information or evidence that proves that something is true.
An app blocker is software that blocks pop-up apps and websites and allows users to set
screen time limits. And designed for addiction describes immersive video games and social media,
which are designed to manipulate human psychology and make it hard to stop playing.
That's all for this program, but if you're interested in the issues around digital technology and
want to find out more, then why not visit the BBC Digital Planet website or follow them on
their Twitter handle at Digital Planet. Bye for now. Goodbye.